dear james cameron i have i have a pitch
for you i know you've been struggling to
get the next avatar movies out but i
think found a solution let me introduce
you to your new virtual
whoops well you know i think you're
gonna love it most of all it's gonna
help you get your movie done fast to
prove to you that this works we're gonna
film an entire scene from avatar 2 and
trust me we i know we don't have the
script but i'm pretty sure we can write
it
welcome to our studio now you've seen it
plenty of times on camera before but
today i have something very special to
show you we've got a lot of big changes
here take a look
what you might think is oh i don't see
anything sam i just see a big old studio
space that's empty you're right we've
moved all the desks up into another unit
so we have vfx workstations up there and
we have studio space down here but what
you can't see is behind these walls is
the mystical world of pandora that's
right the world from avatar why are we
talking about avatar well
let me explain as you guys have seen
i've been messing around with a lot of
unreal engine over the last few months
here so i made a very big promise
recently on our website corridor
digital.com there's an exclusive show
called local xero done in virtual
production all done in real time what
you've been watching is
me my performance my face my body etc
it's pretty crazy and that's what makes
virtual production so special and it's
not greenlit yet which is a good thing
because i'm not ready to shoot it i kind
of over promised a little bit we can
utilize real-time game engines to create
stories you've never
seen before
we don't have the tools available to
create it yet i thought we kind of did
but in further consideration i'm
realized how under prepared we are to
make something of that scale using
virtual production tools when i did the
video game characters react video i shot
that in quarantine all by myself so in
order to film that i had to do every
process one step at a time what's
another large-scale virtual production
project that's been completed the first
that came to mind was
avatar avatar is the perfect benchmark
for us to hit they have virtual cameras
virtual actors and best of all they're
all combined in one thing so you can
actually frame up your actors in your
virtual
scene so before we go into making local
zero we have to make avatar
two
we're talking about multiple actors
we're talking about a cameraman and
somehow this all just works we're
talking about multiple face captures
multiple body captures we're doing
camera captures not to mention we have
to freaking design the whole scene and
the characters and the models and like i
just hope my computer can handle it
because this is gonna be a lot of data
spitting at it
so let's walk through everything i'm
going to need to put together for this
to work let's start with the actors the
actors well we need to capture their
body and their face performance in the
past we use the xn's suits and i love
them they are super high quality the
data's great only challenge they're a
little bit pricey can't afford a second
one right now so because of that we're
going to use the rococo suits we have
two cocoa suits at the studio now each
with a pair of smart gloves for doing
two actors this will be our solution the
only issue is they don't track where you
are in world space and if you have
multiple actors that's a huge challenge
you need actors to be able to look at
each other and have the models actually
line up so to do that and accomplish
this we're going to use a vr headset is
our intermediary we're going to attach
vive trackers to their backs and so as
they're using the suits the suits are
calculating where their arms and body
and legs are moving and these with the
lighthouses up there are going to make
sure that they are in the right space
with each other and that's a very
crucial step without this literally
you'll have two actors in these suits
but on your screen they'll be like
facing completely different directions
and it's gonna look super weird so this
will solve that hashtag spatial
continuity so we've got two actors boom
they're facing each other wow cool
they're interacting we still have to
film it though i want to film these
scenes as they are happening just like
james cameron did we all saw he had a
little computer monitor there that was
tracking his movements and he could
actually frame up a shot that could be
used in the final piece and i love that
ability so we have our vive wands here
and these are tracked in the same space
that the suits are all i have to do is
somehow turn this into a screen and i
think i know how i'm gonna do that
basically i'm going to attach a camera
to it in the engine so as i move this
around the camera will match this
movement but i'm going to need more than
that how am i going to see it how do i
put it i have to put a screen on here
somehow for this we're going to kind of
go back to a slightly more traditional
camera rig i got to put this all
together somehow so
what we got a thing here screw a handle
on it got a clamp so i can clamp my
handset onto it this is working and then
i want a screen so i'm going to put a
it's a really nice monitor look at this
thing aperture monitor it's huge this is
going to be my window into our virtual
universe i need to power it all like a
battery on here
like i'm not concerned with how this
looks because in in unreal engine it's
all going to look really cool tape that
on there i got to do wireless video from
my pc to here so i'm going to use like a
nerius plug this in here oh yeah i got
to power this
all right cool done look at this it's so
professional like you could see me on a
big budget set like this and like yeah
blend right in we have a virtual camera
rig now too
now all we have to do
is somehow combine all this and get it
to start working
[Music]
this is just simply getting the camera
working all i'm trying to do here is
hold that camera rig i built and i want
to see on that screen basically what i
would see through the lens of my virtual
camera wireless video is working check
it out i got my own little mini pc in
here dang look at that so there's my
little pc on here so this is great my
vive controller is turned on i'm gonna
just fire this up and see if it's
tracking anything whoa okay it's
tracking on this screen so i'm gonna
launch this in a new window okay and i'm
gonna drag this new window
over here we go it's working hey this is
a piece of cake i can just frame shots
up i'm like oh let's get a nice shot of
this table okay currently i can't pull
focus that's where mapping all these
buttons is going to come to play so i
can use this and go click click click
click and i want to be able to have my
controls for the camera here so i don't
have to walk back to the computer each
time i need to make an adjustment but
check that out this is working look at
that
oh and there's someone coming down the
stairs
it's so so fun dude i just built a
portal into an imaginary universe
like how crazy is this look at this it
works
you still doubting me done easy virtual
cameras easy i don't know i don't they
don't have like a million of these on
set come on jimmy don't break it so wow
this is literally exactly the same as
what they used on avatar
so what's next well peter has already
set up the rococo suits with vive
trackers so i'm going to leave that to
the very end instead i'm going to get
this camera working 100 get some
controls just like the most basic
control features i need and then we're
going to combine it with the suits the
last thing that's needed for this beast
function is a cool environment and
really cool looking well rigged
characters so for the environments i'm
just going to be compiling assets from
the unreal marketplace but for the
characters sam lazarus who's actually
the creative director of rococo
volunteered to create some navi aliens
fully rigged using daz 3d they have
great materials the blend shapes for the
facial expressions are really good it
looks like these are ready to plug and
play
your tubes are showing dude my tubes the
cubes are dude don't look at my tubes
never look at another man's tubes
today is a big day today is a day where
we will hopefully reach a milestone
where the virtual camera rig and the
actor can intersect in order to do this
we have peter here in a rococo suit a
piece of technology that he is an expert
at and i am not what we have to do today
is get the suit just simply working in
rococo studio then we have to take the
rococo studio data and get that over to
unreal where we'll have a little test
character
it's very important that we put peter's
head on this model
because it's the only way he'll be able
to know it's him in the computer and
won't be afraid and think it's like some
sort of demon
so yeah
okay so i just got off the phone with
sam about 15 minutes ago and he said
that he's completely bogged down in the
technical aspects of getting this rig up
and running and all the rest he's asked
me to step in and write the script for
this avatar 2 video now sam said if i
don't do it that he's just going to come
up with a procedurally generated ai
script uh which i don't even know what
that means but it does not sound good i
know that this episode is sponsored by
squarespace but i promise that's not
gonna affect the story that i'm about to
tell you in any way at all tell me if
you like it
one day jake and terry are out hunting
big game on the moon that they live on
and they come into a clearing and what
is there but a giant polished spaceship
that looks like a giant cube what is
this giant square spaceship and
deterio's like it kind of looks to me
like an all-in-one platform to build a
beautiful online presence and run your
business and jake's like that doesn't
make any sense at all and she's like i
think you'll see that they have all the
tools to allow anyone who's running a
small business without any prior
knowledge of web design to build a
beautiful website for their business
have you seen the size of this square
spaceship and jake's like we've got
video blocks that's right you can embed
videos from anywhere across the internet
onto your square spaceship she's like
that's a very good insight jake because
you know what else you can do with this
square spaceship you can create a
squarespace members area connect with
your audience and generate revenue
through gated members only content isn't
that awesome jake's like yeah it pretty
much is and you know what if you have a
small team you can have multiple
contributors contribute with different
levels of access to your square
spaceship and then like finally what
happens when we get this square
spaceship up and off into the sky and
deteriorates like well we can use the
traffic overviews tools to examine you
know key insights from our website over
time unique visitors page views things
like that top traffic sources and then
jake's like you know what natheri i love
you so much and she's like i know i love
you too let's get in the square
spaceship and let's take off together to
squarespace.com corridor crew to get 10
off the first purchase of our website or
domain and it's beautiful and they take
off off the moon they live happily ever
after on another moon squarespace.com
corridor crew to get 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain that's
what avatar 2 is about i think it's
going to be a great great one i think
sam's absolutely going to love it
are you are you free jake's script was
pretty
good ai script generator it's working
great all we got to do is feed it
prompts to keep writing the script from
the end of avatar one and i just wonder
if you want to maybe hop in throw in a
few prompts with me i'm in let's do it
i want to see my expectations defied
maybe before we even get into this
what's avatar 2 gonna probably be about
so avatar 1 is just pocahontas in space
so what's a good generic story that just
needs some aliens in it oh my name is
julia romeo juliet and juliet i'm down
for romeo and juliet okay i think we
should just get right to scripting this
it seems like this could be really easy
so what we have in front of us is the
entire script for the first avatar and
txt document all right copy
man so the first movie just ended with
he becomes an alien and then cuts to
black okay all right so the next movie
is going to start probably with like a
oh where are we exterior pandora's
jungle two alien
uh
creatures
walk through the dense jungle on the
hunt for a a new unobtanium a new
element that's even more powerful than
fun obtainium
what's what's the alien's name jake and
nathery no no no no i'm walking through
the dense jungle
it's a sequel we have to introduce new
characters jake is not jake it's
jorbot we don't want to get sued jorbot
and willis jorbon willis walk through
the dense jungle when suddenly a
spaceship flies overhead and lands they
discuss what to do next
okay so this is what we have to shoot
yeah
you discuss what to do next here you be
you be jorbot i'll be willis
take cover and fire when you see the
ship uh not unless you're ready to fight
us sir an unarmed nurura is not a threat
to us how will we know when he's ready
just keep going i'm on the edge of my
seat how long we know he's ready asking
the question i suppose you could say
we'll know when it starts getting hot
long pause or
is it hot all right we're already in the
next scene exterior spaceship there's a
small cooking fire in the center of the
ship something from the gentroni
it seems so it's bigger than their
spaceship a perfect square
it's the mirror image of the navi ship
jake inspects it
now they've ever seen anything like that
what do you suppose it is it's
definitely not human no lights a black
block a gray box with a door in it the
word not sulu
is stenciled in it in navi characters
this is getting good this is mysterious
nathiri goes to open the hatch new
character apparently named
ali she burst out hey girl where are you
going
hey terry
there's no way to get in that way come
on come on nick theory closes the hatch
this is great jake and deteri rush
[Laughter]
and then he pulls out a gun hey back off
jake get out of the way
hey
out of breath oh
[Laughter]
uh-oh uh-oh
now introducing
the star brian
what where's it going this gets us off
to a pretty good start what's crazy it
really has the feeling of the original
film it feels like this is the sequel
you want to see
that's that's the uh the power of ai
today's the big day after weeks of work
i have gotten things about like 80 good
that's enough okay you are my motion
capture actors emotion capture i think
you came to the right two bros to do
that here is the script and i'm gonna
tell you guys your characters uh jake
sullivan or whatever his name is all
right i will you're jake all right all
right you are uh
you're nakiri so am i wait am i
sigourney weaver no the the main lady
alien make sure you deliver all this
with a very feminine undertone that'll
be easy for me the question is who's
going to be the better improv artist
can peter do this
can peter do this give me something give
me anything crab crab
peter toaster
that was pretty good that was pretty
good a little bit of the plan here today
first i think we should do a quick read
through here like a table read it's a
nine page script and that's a little
intimidating considering we're gonna
shoot this in a few hours my
relationship with with peter's character
are we friends
it seems like you're lovers kind of dude
are we lovers we probably are
there are multiple times in the scene
where we look deeply into each other's
eyes
do you get a little jealous when this
when um holly gives me her heart dude
honestly are you like that like in my
heart i know i have nothing to worry
about because
you'll love me till the end of time yeah
still like my primitive brain is like yo
that other
alien is kind of sexy and i don't know
i yeah it's
that that personally made me a little
jealous just a little bit
once we're done with that and we're
familiar with the scenes we'll put our
suits on and we're going to do the
scenes and hopefully this won't take all
day i don't think it will because unlike
a normal film set i'm only gonna be like
capturing one angle of each scene and
i'll add the rest in later because of
that i think things will go a little
faster than your traditional nine page
script i'm hoping to have a super super
sweet avatar two scene that makes people
satisfied after watching it people been
waiting for years to take a peek at
avatar 2. so
he's going to put a rocket ship on the
moon and everyone's going to go like wow
great work but someone did it first you
know and those guys are
people who are truly rooted in history
[Music]
so i thought things were going well
psych actually things haven't been going
well this is that part in the video okay
you know the part in the video where ren
like slams his head on a table and is
silent you get the wide shot of him like
being really depressed that's where i am
right now i'm at my lowest low we did
our mocap session clinton peter we're
doing mocap everything that could go
wrong went wrong the data every single
screw and bolt that could go loose on it
went loose the rococo suits are great
but right now with where they're at they
don't seem like they're the best fit for
doing this style of motion capture once
you have two actors in your scene and
you're doing this virtual camera and all
the space data and the smart gloves that
live link process where you're streaming
data into unreal is dependent on the
frame rate that your computer is running
at and when i have a full scene open
with characters and the frame rate's
inconsistent the motion capture data
sucks right now i have all the scenes
set up but they look like absolute
garbage because the rococo application
can't stream the data at a high enough
frame rate for it to look even like
remotely smooth i don't even want to
show you guys what it looks like right
now because
it's it's so
far from where i'm hoping it can be like
i'm okay with some jank here i'm i'm
okay with some goofs but it's it's at a
point where if you looked at it you
would just see pure
incompetence and i feel like
we can do a little bit better than that
at the end of the day i was just like i
i give up guys let's put the camera down
let's just record you guys doing your
performance let me watch you as a
director should not worrying about all
this stuff get what we need from you
guys
and go with that
let's call it that's a that's a wrap
avatar 2 sam's best learning experience
actually what did i learn well when i
went into this project i thought having
a virtual camera with these virtual
actors would be something that would
help unlock more creativity but in doing
this i realized it's actually the
opposite it it hinders it i mean well if
you're working with a small crew it's a
bunch of extra technical stuff big
productions have multiple crew members
and technicians and all this stuff and
i'm trying to like still find that nice
streamlined process like what can three
people make two actors and a director
the beauty about this whole thing is
that i can always add the camera in
later sure it's cool it's novel being
able to see a person in a mocap suit as
their digital self but
that doesn't actually go towards making
a better piece that's what it comes down
to i can move the characters wherever i
want afterwards what i did build for the
camera is still gonna pay off but the
whole process of directing and capturing
a virtual production performance it just
doesn't seem like the camera is a
necessary part of it did you hear is it
time
[Music]
now i'm gonna be judged by the honey
tear community don't like this whatever
you're doing
it's time it's time it's time it's time
it's done i can't wait to see my
favorite characters jake sully and
nathiri
those two characters that i can
definitely name i don't have enough
dimensions to describe my expectations
right now
i'm good
it's a lot of people
i didn't need everyone to watch it so uh
welcome to the screening of avatar 2. we
we
did it we beat james cameron it's taken
10 years to produce nothing it took me
three weeks to produce this we basically
had an ai read through the original
avatar script and then it gave us this
masterpiece
what
yes
sam i wrote the script and i gave it to
you like last week there's too much we
didn't have the resources to produce
your vision so who cares here we go
three two one world premiere go
what created the most anxiety for me
over this project was releasing this so
close to another virtual production
thing that is on our website that people
have put their producer points towards
you know it's not a free product and i
want to make sure it's really really
good so i am anxious about how this
looks and how that potentially shines a
negative light on what this next project
is going to be like but trust me that
when i say i'm aware of the problems we
ran into and am going to fix them well
i'm going to i actually i honestly think
that after this any uh chance of ever
speaking to james cameron ever
are
completely gone
[Music]
get down
what kind of thing is that
something from the ginger honey
i don't think i've ever seen anything
like that
what do you suppose it is
it's definitely not human i don't want
to scare it but if there's anything to
not be in this dimension it's probably a
passenger
why would they need a passenger they
could just dump it inside the ship
the pods no bigger than a hatchback jake
well let's just go back and ask them
hey girl where are you going
there's no way to get in this way
hey come on come on come on
what if it's a girl it's probably just a
bunch of uplanders by the color of their
skin maybe but
maybe it's not
something's not right
come on come on
[Music]
i'd sure like to know what that was
about
hey get out of the way
hey get back
what the hell was that about
hey
what is this
[Music]
[Music]
hey hey wait
we're not just gonna leave you here
jake come on
hey hey come on
[Music]
hey
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
he thinks he knows
and he's not afraid anymore
yeah maybe so
[Music]
[Music]
pandora brought me here from within its
planet
and the tree gave me life
it protected us here
and now we are ready to take back
pandora
this mineral may look strange
but it has an even more powerful magic
inside of it
even more powerful than unobtanium
it changes everything we touch if we
touch the fire and it touches our hands
if it touches our feet we will burn
we are a weapon that can destroy but
only if we stay in touch
when we touch it
we lose our magic
it can't be in both our hands it has to
stay in one
i guess that means you're gonna show us
how to get out of here
with one hand
i carry a gift
with the other
i hold the power of destruction
[Applause]
just like uh i'm giving you my heart oh
can i have it no
yeah okay
i only have a short time left
every moment is precious
i'm giving this to you
please
use it to protect the tree
uh
[Music]
and so the celia tells him he will never
wear a mask again and will never fight
to protect the planet
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a beautifully flawed piece twist at
the end i couldn't have possibly seen
coming
i could just
so it felt nice to finally have people
see the video i've been working on for
so long and we got some good laughs in
there most of the laughs were just the
text i put on screen and not the actual
video itself but uh yeah the piece is
flawed but i'm happy i went through this
experience figuring this stuff out
trying out some new hardware here really
testing it with a workflow because
regardless there's a lot of really good
learning experiences that i was able to
go through the rococo suits are really
cool but you know they're still very
much untested in a production
environment and that's what we finally
created here today you know everyone
including the manufacturers of these
suits are trying to figure out what are
the best practices and what are the best
ways for people to do this because the
real potential here is you know we are
on the verge of being able to make
animated films with human actors and
human animators and human cameramen the
technology
is almost there that's what's still very
exciting about it in the future here for
like local zero or other virtual
production pieces we're going to have to
find another way to get there thankfully
there's a million paths forward still in
the meantime we're gonna figure out
which one's the next best one if you
guys enjoyed this video and want to see
other wacky motion capture experiments
subscribe to this channel also
if you want to see the anti-circus
olympics using motion capture technology
let us know in the comments